good afternoon everyone my name is
researcher Miller and today we are going
to be studying scp-173 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
item scp-173 is to be kept in a locked
container at all times when personnel
must enter a CP 173 s container no fewer
than three may enter at any time and the
door is to be relocked behind them at
all times two persons must maintain
direct eye contact with a CP 173 until
all personnel have vacated and relocked
the container description moved to site
19 in 1993 origin is as of yet unknown
it is constructed from concrete and
rebar with traces of Krylon brand
spray-paint scp-173 is animate and
extremely hostile the object cannot move
within direct line of sight line of
sight must not be broken at any time
with scp-173 the personnel assigned to
enter container are instructed to alert
one another before blinking object is
reported to attack by snapping the neck
at the base of the skull or by
strangulation in the event of an attack
personnel are to observe class for
hazardous object containment procedures
personnel report sounds of scraping
stone originating from within the
container when no one is present inside
this is considered normal and any change
in this behavior should be reported to
the acting HM CL supervisor on duty the
reddish-brown substance on the floor is
a combination of feces and blood origin
of these materials is unknown the
enclosure must be cleaned on a bi-weekly
basis this was a very short lecture
today but suffice to say we will be
covering much longer documents in the
future thank you very much for listening
you are all dismissed thank you
you